[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
jury selection for the trial of the
death of a mod arbory we prefer that
jurors be clean slates that they have no
position on the case
in a county as small and close-knit as
glenn county that is proven to be an
impossible task law on crime daily is
live in georgia with the latest and
florida police admit a mistake in the
brian laundry investigation what
incorrect identification officers made
plus we're here today to announce that
we have identified yet another one of
the victims of john gacy's
massacres four decades after his murder
a victim of the so-called killer clown
is identified
and later
i would never kill your queen like that
markeith loyd addresses the court in his
own murder trial moments before
testimony begins law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everybody to long crime daily
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
along with terry austin jury selection
moves forward in the trial for the death
of a mod arbory as three men face
charges for the 25 year old's murder
father and son duo gregory and travis
mcmichael and neighbor william roddy
bryant face several charges including
malice murder felony murder and
aggravated assault
in february 2020 arbory was reportedly
jogging near his brunswick home when the
mcmichaels began to tail him in a pickup
truck travis mcmichael eventually shot
him claiming self-defense brian filed
along in his own vehicle and recorded
the incident on his cell phone the video
was later released causing national
uproar arbory a black man was unarmed at
the time of his death jury selection for
the tri the state trial began last
monday and on tuesday the defense moved
to make the area outside of the
courthouse a
demonstration-free zone citing comments
made by civil rights attorney lee
merritt the judge denied that motion
long crime daily's brian buckmeyer spoke
with merritt outside the courthouse
i think william roddy brian is poorly
represented i think his attorney should
be focusing on things that actually
impact the outcome of the trial
this is his opportunity to
say a popular name get his face on tv
uh it's asinine i think the court has
agreed with that i've gotten used to it
um there was an early motion about me
wearing a george floyd mass uh to the
trial for the men who murdered the mod
are berry the two don't conflate but
there was a motion for mr goth anyway
this seems to be what he does
all right let's go now to brian
buckmeyer who's live in georgia brian
it's good to see you you were at the
glen county courthouse today when the
defense made these comments can you
break down the defense's motion and how
it involved lee merritt exactly
yes jesse so this morning at 8 30 first
thing in the morning the defense made
the oral motions that for a number of
things one that they wanted any kind of
demonstrators or protesters here at the
scene to be pushed further back than
where they are right now they are just
out front inside of the courthouse
peacefully just sitting there and
oftentimes breaking out into song as you
noted also making comments as to lee
merritt's
instagram and social and other social
media posts uh talking about jury
selection as well as a general process
of picking uh in this case uh also spoke
about uh the responses generally from
lehman who is the civil rights attorney
and it was interesting as to how that
played out after that as you saw lee
merritt made those responses as to
william rhodey brian's attorney and also
we got a bit of a notion as to when this
trial or at least the jury selection
part of the trial may come to an end
so brian let's talk about lee merritt
for real quick because the judge didn't
seem to be too happy with the comments
that he made on social media i said he's
basically going to take her under an
advisement and figure out what to do
with it later any concern from merit on
the statements from the court there
not really merit actually to some degree
applauded the judge as you saw there
earlier saying and i agree with him that
the judge is very professional
understanding that not everyone's going
to agree with the judge's decisions and
taking to kind of taking that hit
so to speak saying hey merrick can
criticize my rulings or however may be
but drawing the line and showing a
little bit of
i would not say disdain but
uncomfortable on comfort in terms of
deciding how far those comments can go
as to how they may affect the jury he
hasn't ruled yet as to what kind of
restrictions he may or may not have but
to the prosecution's point that's not an
individual who's a part of this case in
any way shape or form it's hard to limit
that individual's free speech brian you
mentioned that may i have a sign of when
jury selection will eventually wrap up
what can you tell us
it was interesting it was kind of an off
the cuff remark made in an argument by
uh defense attorney sheffield saying
that we should marry the six prospective
jurors from this week with the eighth of
next week to try to expedite the process
so to speak and he said that if we were
able to do this
we may have all we need by the end of
the trial now the defense
point was kind of declined by the judge
they weren't going to do that but in his
discussions with the judge in the court
of trying to push forward in this
process it appears at least by defense
attorney sheffield that we may have jury
selection ending either by the end of
the week or sometime early next week all
right well it's easy to say it but this
is becoming a very complicated process
no shadow of a doubt about that and
we'll see which way it goes brian
buckmeyer thanks so much appreciate it
as always
over now to an update to a story that we
first brought you earlier this week a
wisconsin judge rules that kyle
rittenhouse's defense can
call a use of force expert a witness in
the upcoming trial 18-year-old
rittenhouse is charged with homicide and
attempted homicide after the august 2020
shootings in kenosha wisconsin
prosecutors say that rittenhouse shot
and killed two people and injured
another during the unrest that followed
the police shooting of jacob blake on
monday rittenhouse appeared in court for
a last minute set of motions before next
week's trial after both sides came to a
compromise on use of force expert
testimony the judge also ruled that the
two deceased men and the man who was
injured could not be referred to as
victims he also allowed a video to be
admitted into evidence that shows police
officers before the shooting telling
written house they appreciated him being
there rittenhouse's team argues that he
acted in self-defense
his trial is set to begin with jury
selection on monday november 1st
and still ahead on law and crime daily a
victim of the so-called killer clown
john wayne gacy is identified more than
four decades after his death but first a
wrong identification of brian laundry
how the police got it wrong after this
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
we are going to make sure that we find
justice in this case the three men
charged will now stand trial i told him
stop stop stop till he hit me i had
nothing to do
nothing else i could do you're a
pacifier coming through not necessarily
that's my son that shot him i was at the
back of the truck
starting october 18th watch live galvado
gavel coverage on the law and crime
network
[Music]
and welcome back everybody police in
northport florida say that they made a
mistake when they were keeping an eye on
brian laundry this is all following the
missing persons report for gabby petitto
long crimes anjanet levy's here with the
somewhat startling admission and
jeannette what do you have for us
yeah jesse this is pretty surprising you
know you may recall back on september
16th northport's police chief said
during a press conference that he knew
where brian laundry was well now
according to a police spokesperson that
turns out to not be true because he says
that officers actually mistook
brian's mother roberta for him now the
laundry family attorney says that brian
left the family's home on september 13th
in a silver mustang to go hiking at the
carlton reserve that police spokesperson
told wink news that officers watching
brian laundry saw the car return to the
home two days later and thought they saw
brian get out and go into the house well
it turns out it was laundry's mother
roberta getting out of that vehicle
after returning from picking up the car
at the carlton reserve meaning that
brian laundry never returned home the
spokesperson told wink the officers felt
brian and roberta had similar builds but
the laundry family attorney stephen
bertolino told me everyone makes
mistakes but brian and roberta are not
built the same bertolino said in a
statement it was nppd that put the
ticket on the mustang at the park and if
they saw brian leave on monday the 13th
in the mustang which is news to me
then they should have been watching the
mustang in the park starting on monday
and they would have known it was chris
and roberta that retrieved the mustang
from the park
now to be clear none of this may have
made a difference with respect to
brian's life but it certainly would have
prevented all of the false accusations
leveled by so many against chris and
roberto with respect to hiding brian or
otherwise financing his quote escape now
bernalino said that law enforcement
officers and the searchers did the best
they could to find brian and that their
efforts are appreciated brian laundry's
skeletal remains were found you'll
recall last week at the carlton reserve
right now a forensic anthropologist is
working on those remains the skeletal
remains to determine his cause of death
if possible jesse all right let's break
it down so we're also joined by co-host
terry austin as well as criminal defense
attorney suanne robinson and jeanette
let me just stick with you for a second
is there any word on whether this
affected the outcome of the
investigation at all i hear what
bertolino said but that the police say
anything
yeah you know it's interesting uh jesse
i have actually reached out to josh
taylor the spokesperson for northport
police he has not yet
returned my email from much earlier in
the day but uh he told another florida
tv station
other than wink that he doesn't believe
it would have made a difference because
it sounds like he believes and maybe now
the other police officers believe based
on the skeletal remains that were
recovered that brian laundry may have
already been been dead by the 15th when
the vehicle returned to the home
well suanne i got to ask with a mistake
like this does it make you wonder were
there other mistakes in the case
of course and that's really why
the officers are coming forward and
admitting their mistake because now
every single part of their investigation
everything they did every question every
witness every photograph everything is
going to be scrutinized
re-scrutinized and looked at a million
times so they really really really have
to dot their eyes and cross their t's in
this case because there's so many eyes
on it and the scrutiny is really what's
going to make sure that we all have the
best information so i don't have an
issue with it but certainly making a
mistake like oh we thought the mom
of brian landrieu was brian landry is a
big mistake considering the type of case
and the high profile of the case terry
we've discussed this issue before got to
bring it up again with this new
development about the confusion between
brian's mother do you think the
laundries could face potential charges
here
listen i know that the police made a
mistake in misidentifying brian but you
have to question whether or not roberto
laundry was being intentionally
deceptive i still believe that they
could be charged with accessory after
the fact you just have to show they knew
about a crime and that they aided in the
escape and i think they can be charged
with obstruction of justice if you think
about it jesse brian laundry came home
on september 1st they went camping
together as a family on september 6th
and 7th they have to know what happened
so i definitely think they're holding
back information and i do think charges
can be made against them i don't know
driving that mustang it's a little
curious to think about and jeannette
thank you so much for reporting on this
appreciate as always coming up on law
and crime daily a victim of serial
killer john wayne gacy is positively
identified how investigators solved the
mystery of a john doe victim more than
40 years after his murder
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back more than four decades
after his murder investigative work and
dna testing helped identify an unknown
john wayne gacy victim as missing man
francis wayne alexander
wayne came here in 75
and was only in here for a short period
of time
he had the misfortune of both living in
the area where john waste wayne gacy did
most of his killing where he target most
of his victims
he also had the misfortune of also
operating an area where john gasey
targeted specific people in specific
groups as well it was like the typical
painstaking work of finding out when
wayne was last seen
tax records
parking tickets that we were able to put
this all together combining with the dna
alexander's remains were found in the
crawl space under gacy's chicago area
home back in 1978 the serial killer was
charged with 33 murders he was dubbed
the so-called killer clown as he often
dressed as a clown and performed at
children's hospitals or events gacy was
sentenced to death and executed in 1994.
on monday the cook county sheriff
announced alexander is a victim citing
police work and scientific research from
the dna doe project dna from alexander's
tooth was sent to three different states
to find a genealogical match the cook
county sheriff says that five of gacy's
victims still remain unidentified but
they say officials say that they will
continue their investigations to
determine who the remaining unidentified
victims are
so suanne how does a discovery like this
tell us more about gacy and of course
his crime spree
it tells you that we don't really know
the extent of
everything he did even post his death
and i think the big big
word of the day for this family is
definitely closure they finally know
what happened to their family member
after so long and that to me is the most
important part of the story
along with how much
police work and investigation goes into
it and that advancements in tech
technology are allowing for cold cases
to be solved so many years later yeah
and that's a great point and terry you
know how important are these kind of dna
genealogy databases and sites when it
comes to identifying unknown victims
it's critically important and it's not
just for victims it's actually for those
people who commit the crimes you
remember in the golden state killer case
the authorities followed him and they
found some of his dna in a discarded
item and they did the same thing they
traced back genealogy and they did find
his
family members and ultimately they did
that police work that we talked about
and it took them back to the killer the
same thing happens with the victims here
they find something and they trace it
back to a family member and that is how
they ultimately are able to find and
swear is right it is the closure that
these family members are getting and
sometimes the family members have to be
really aggressive as far as chasing this
down and following up with authorities
to make sure they figure out what
happened to their family member yeah and
it's great that law enforcement never
gave up and maybe we'll have an end to
cold cases moving forward moving on to
news out of new york where eric garner's
family is pushing back with a judicial
inquiry seven years after he died at the
hands of nypd officers you might recall
that in 2014 garner was approached by
police officers who say he was selling
cigarettes without tax stamps and now
former police officer daniel pantaleo
attempted to arrest garner who pulled
his arms away pantaleo then placed his
arm around garner's neck and wrestled
him to the ground as multiple officers
pinned him down garner repeated the
words i can't breathe 11 times while
face down on the sidewalk garner lost
consciousness and was later pronounced
dead hours later at the hospital a
ground a grand jury decided to not
indict pantaleo and an out of court
settlement was reached with the city of
new york and the garner family pantaleo
was later fired in 2019. that was five
years after the incident on monday
garner's mother and other
petitioners began their judicial inquiry
it's actually a rarely used legal
process that allows members of the
public to investigate alleged neglect of
duty by public officials in new york
city judge erica edwards stated that she
will not charge anyone at the end of the
inquiry and that the questioning will
focus on what really happened leading up
to garner's death
when we come back testimony begins in
florida from markeith lloyd's second
murder trial you're going to hear from
the defendant who addresses the court
about his arrest and what he says is
important in this case stay with us
welcome back everybody after nearly 12
days of jury selection jurors are seated
and testimony is underway in the second
murder trial of markeith loyd lloyd is
being tried for the murder of lieutenant
debra clayton who he shot outside of a
walmart while she was pursuing him in
january 2017. at the time lloyd was
running from from authorities after
killing his pregnant ex-girlfriend
shaudai dixon you might recall that in
2019 lloyd was found guilty of dixon's
murder now he originally faced the death
penalty but was later sentenced to life
with no parole if lloyd is convicted in
this murder case he will face the death
penalty again opening statements
officially began on monday after jury
selection concluded lloyd previously
requested that he represent himself in
this case having little faith in his
defense team and following their opening
statements on monday he expressed those
concerns once again
and then an opening he left out
an important part of my defense which
everyone should know what these jurors
should know even if even miss clayton's
family should know how to turn myself in
two times before walmart they don't want
to talk about that they don't want the
jury to know
walmart never had to happen
these people know these people know i
these people know
that i believe the police were trying to
kill me and they told no one
they endangered the devil me and
everyone else but they told no way and
they trying to keep the jury and the
people from knowing this
and this judge is working with them
and walmart never had to have i tried to
turn myself in two times before walmart
i know i would never kill your queen
like that never
okay so suanne if you have a client
who's unhappy with your representation
he gets convicted and sentenced does
that mean that that client is
automatically entitled to a new trial
no
the client would have to file a motion
and
the
the conduct of the attorney would have
to rise to a certain level in order for
him to be entitled to a new trial or or
the standard of the attorney's
uh
representation would have to be very low
in order for him to be granted a new
trial i think you know he's in a unique
situation where he already has a life
sentence pending so if he chooses to
represent himself you know he's he's
kind of you know not to make light of it
but he's kind of playing with house
money he's already facing a life
sentence well here's the thing terry
right if markeith lloyd's convicted of
murder the you know for the death of uh
officer clayton do you think he could
escape the death sentence once again he
testified in his first trial maybe he'll
testify again you know what jesse he
could escape the death sentence again
and i think he will testify on this
stand but i think this time it's going
to be different the prosecution's
opening was amazing they listed the fact
that they have multiple witnesses who
identified him at this walmart we know
he shot clayton four different times he
also shot at another officer who was
tracking him down he stopped a bystander
and took his car this individual is
ruthless and tried very hard to get away
so i think the other issue here is
the prosecution mentioned in their
opening that he wasn't diagnosed with
mental illness until after he was on
trial i think if the jury looks at all
of that they could very well sentence
him to death maybe all right wait and
see particularly if he takes the stand
suanne terry thank you so much everyone
out there thanks for joining us here on
long crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you